[Music]
camboni beach zamboni that's pretty cool
love that all right well i don't see a
lot of sand here at least not in town
we've got a lot of sand around us and
it's heating up
it's also pretty windy in some spots and
we're already seeing those gusts that
have been over 20 25 miles an hour in
many locations west henderson almost 25
mile an hour winds temperatures in the
90s boulder city closer to 30 mile an
hour winds and up in the mountains as
well let's check valley temperatures all
around in the 90's now summerlin still
just barely hanging on to upper 80's
even 90 with gusty winds out at red rock
75 with breezy winds up at kyle canyon
kingman has had 35 mile an hour winds 91
in kingman almost 100 in laughlin right
now mid 90s for boulder city 99 in
mesquite and quite windy also in indian
springs and more of a southeast wind
today 91 there 94 in death valley is
already over 100 degrees also some wind
for ely 63 there 86 as well in caliente
82 in cedar springs so wind just for
about everybody it's the way the days
have been going heating up and getting
breezy 101 today just like yesterday and
again the normal 104.
the record for today 115 and we're going
to be closer to those record highs
next week as we get a pretty good heat
wave building in so dry and breezy
afternoons through friday get your ac
tuned up change those filters get ready
you're going to have a long period of
that ac working overtime to keep you
cool so those extra hot temperatures up
around 110 maybe even 110 plus for us
next week more rain and cool weather
into the pacific northwest a really
large area of low pressure there showers
through the rockies today but let's talk
about the big heat wave across the east
and southeast check out raleigh durham
102 right now but their heat index is
114
with 40 percent humidity it feels like
low triple digits in little rock and
dallas that heat wave is going to last
into the weekend all right so we've got
this southerly flow as long as that low
is off the coast it will start lifting
inland and move up towards canada
tomorrow and friday and that will take
the winds with it so the winds will
start to calm down and the temperatures
will start to heat up low triple digits
a little below normal today and tomorrow
and then wow up of 1-7 108 for the
weekend and up near 110 next week we're
going to be wishing for those winds to
come back john